♪
>>esse: AND INDIANA ECATOR
NAMED TO KENNETT RECENTLY CAME
ON T SHOW TO SPEAK OUT AGAINSTCS
HE EXPOSED THEACT THAT COUNTER
TO WHA OFFICIALS WERE TELLING
PARENTS, RACISTS CRT WAS, IN
FACT, BEEN TAUGH TO KIDS.
>> WE CAN OFFICIALLY TELL
PARES WE ARE NOTEACHING
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, IT'S N
IN THE INDNA ACADEMIC
STANDARDS, BUT ALL OF A SUDN,
THE CLASSROOM DR SHOTS AND THE
ACHER STARTS TEACHING, THROUGHAF
ESSENTIALISM THAT PIT STUDENTS
AGAINST EACH OER BASED ON
THEIR COLOR.
>> Jesse: FOR SAYING TT
TER TELLING THE TRUTH,ONY
KENNT MAY LOSEIS JOB.
HE HASEEN RECOMMENDED FOR
FIRING FOLLOWING AUSPENSION
AND INVESTIGATION.
HE JOINS US NOW.
DID THEY GIVE YOU A LEGITIMATE
REAS?
DID THEY SAY, YOU KW, YOU WENT
ON FOX AND SAIDHIS, OR DID
THEY COOK UP SOME B.S.
INFRACTI AND U THAT TO
JUSTIFY UR FIRING?
>> YOU HAD TO USE THE WORD
"LEGITIMATE," DIDN' YOU?
BE CBL TOGETHEQUITE AEW
CHARSHAT REALLY HAD NOTHINGTOO F
CRITIC RACE THEORY, AT
LEAST  THE SURFACE.
OFOURSE, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
CHARGES SAYING I USED THE
INDIANAPOLIS PUBLI FILES FOR MY
OWN PERSONALAIN,HAT I HAD
MISQUOTED DISTRICT OFFICIALS,
WHICH OF COUE ISN'T TRUE, AND
REALISTICALLY IN THE MEETINGS,
THOUGH, THEYHINED ABOUT MY
APPEARIN ON "TUCKERARLSON
TONIGHT" SEVERAL TIMES AND EVERY
NGLE MEETING, WHETHER ITAS
HR OR MY SUPERVIR YELLING AT
ABOUT IT, EVERYONE WAS
HORRIFIED TH I WOULD SHARE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLEMAILS ON
FOX NEWS.
>> THIS WAS PUBCLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION, PART OF THECURRICUH
TH PUBLIC.
IT SEEMS LIKE TH ARE ASHAMED,
THEY ARE EMBARRASSED BECAUSE YOU
EXPOSED THE FTHEYRE
TEACHING UNPOPULAR AND
SUBVERSIVE MERIALS TO
SCHOOLCHILEN.
IS THAT HOW YOU ASSESS IT
>> AOLUTELY.
WE INVITED THE INDIE BLA LIVES
MATTERS AUDIENCE T SPEAK TO
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS AND TAUGHT
STUDENTS "CRIME DOES NOT EXIST,
IT IS MADEP," AND THAT W
REIRED FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
STUDENTSURING THE DAY.
OUR CURCULUM OFFICE HAD NO
ABOUT IT.
WE TELL THE PUBLIC IT IS GNG
ON, I IS EMBAASSMENT, DOESNOT MY
AVAILABLE INFORTION, IT IS
IRRELEVANT, PPLE DID NOT SIGN
UP TO HAVE THEIRMAILS A
FILES IN FRONT OF THE PUBLIC,
ANOF COURSE, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: SO, THE
SUPERINTENDENT,HO WTS TO
NAIL YR HIDE TO THE WALL,
DR. ALICIA JNSON, SHE WAN
YOU FIRED, SHE SAYS SHE IS GOING
TO FIRE YOU
DOES SHE HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN THE
COMMUNITY?
IOULD ASSUME YOU WLD HAVE
THE SUPRT OF PARENTS, TEA
TEACHERS, SHE JUST DOI THIS ON
A WHIM BECAUSEHE DOESN'T LIK
YOU ANDHE WANTS TO KEEP THE
FACT TT SHE IS POISONG
CHILDR'S BRAINS SECRET?
>> THERE HAS REALLY BEEN A
COERTED EFFORT INNDIANAPOLIS
PUBLIC SCHOOL TO COVER UP THE
ACTIONS OF DR. PRICIA PAINE'S,
DIRECTOR OFACIAL EQUIT SHE
RU THE RACIAL EQUITY OFFICE IN
THE DISTRICT, AND REALISTICALLY
THE ENTIRE UPPER ADMINISTRION
HAS BEEN HORRIED THAT I
HAVE BN SHARING THESE PUBLIY
AVAILABLE DOCUMENTWITH THE
PUBLIC.
AS FAR AS SUPPORT,E HAVE BEENBLF
PARENTALUPPORT IN THE
COMMUNITY, A LOT OF TEAERS
FROM INSIDE INDIAPOLIS AND
SOME PNCLES HAVE REACHED OUT
SPREAD THEIR SUPPORT AND THE
DO NOTIKEHAT IS GOING ON
INDE INDIANAPOLIS EHER, AND
REALISTICALLY, THE RATIO OF
SUPPORT TO CRITICI HAS BEEN
IMMENSELY POSITIVEND WE AREVERY.
>> Jes: AND DO YOU HAV A
GOOD LAWYER?
>> [LAUGHS]
YES, I HAVE AN EXLLENT LEGAL
AM.
THEY HAVE BEEN PHENOMENAL I
MAKING SE THAT I RECEID
LEGAL SUPPO, EVEN WHEN
INDIANAPOLIS BANNED MEROM
HAVI AN ATTORNEY, WE AUALLY
HAD TO FIGHT FOR 20 MINUTES IN
HR MEETING SO TT I COULD GET
THE SAMEEPRESENTATION RIGHTS
THAT EVERYONE ELSE HAS.
IT WAS EMBARRASSNT.
>> Jesse: WOW.IF WE HAVE LEARNEG
ROUGHOUT THIS PANDEMIC, SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS,OME OF THEM,
NOT ALL OF THEM, BUT SOME OF
THEM COU POSSIBLY B SOME OF
THE WORST PEOPL
WE DIDN'T KNOW THATEFORE, BUT
IT IS BECOMING MORE CLEAR.
TONY KINNETT, GOOD LUCK.
U ARE GOINGO NEE